[موسيقى]
كان يحلم بان يصبح لاعب كره قدم ورسم بول
ماسكل حلمه داخل المستطيل الاخضر لكن
اصابه عنيفه حرمته من فرصه مواصله المشوار
فشعر بخيبه امل كبرى ثم نهض من جديد وغير
البوصله نحوه هوليود وبات النجم الاصغر
بين كبار المرشحين للاوسكار فما قصته ولد
بولماسكل عام
1996 في ايرلندا والدته ضابطه في الشرطه
ووالده مدرس وممثل وهو الابن الاكبر
لثلاثه اشقاء اثناء الطفولته كان لاعب كره
قدم ضمن صفوف فريق نادي
لسن تحت 21 عاما
اثناء ممارسته الرياضه التي احبها مره بول
بانتكاسه كبرى عندما تعرض لاصابه في الفك
فترك كره القدم واعتزل اللعب مكرها ثم
اتجه الى الفن وبدا يبحث عن ذاته على خشبه
المسرح مرتكنا على كونه لعب وهو في سن
السادسه عشر دور فانتم في المسرحيه
الموسيقيه
اما الخطوه الجديه في مسيرته فبدات عندما
التحق باكاديميه لير التابعه لكليه ترونتي
في دبلن وحصل على بكالوريوس الاداب في
التمثيل عام 2017 في بدايه اعماله قام
بدور جيجاتسبي في مسرحيه
ثم لعب دور الامير في اعاده سرد حديثه
لرائعه
لت عروض المسرح على ماسكل بفضل ادائه
المتميز فحصل على دور مهم في العرض
العالمي الاول لمسرحيه اسكين كما ظهر في
اجزاء من عرض امرنايتد الذي عرض ضمن
فعاليات مهرجان
للفنون في ذلك العام
اثناء ذلك
ظهر بول ماسكل في اعلان تجاري لشركه داني
وهي شركه منتجه للنقانق واشتهر من خلاله
بشكل كبير حتى اصبح يكنى
ثم لعب دور بطل رومانسي في المسلسل
الدرامي الايرلندي نورمال وحزى عنه جائزه
الاكاديميه البريطانيه للافلام البافته
وجائزه التلفزيون والسينما الايرلنديه كما
حصل على ترشيح لجائزه
قبل ان يقدم اول فيلم طويل له في عام 2021
عندما
ظهر كعامل شاطئ في الفيلم الدرامي
وهو الدور الذي قدمه للمجتمع السينمائي
حصل مسكل على المزيد من الفرص في العام
التالي فظهر بدور الاب الشاب في الدراما
ثم كرجل متهم جنائيا فيه
وكلاهما عرض لاول مره في مهرجان كان
السينمائي عام 2022 وحصل على تقييمات
ايجابيه في العام نفسه اختير ماسكا لبطوله
فيلم كارمن المقتبس من الاوبرا التي تحمل
الاسم نفسه كما ظهر في فيلم الخيال العلمي
فو المقتبس من روايه
خلال عقد من الزمن لعب ماسكا الادوارا
رئيسيه عده وقدم 20 عملا فنيا على الاقل
جعلته نجما في فتره قياسيه ونجح في حصد
جوائز عده بالاضافه الى البافته كجائزه
مهرجان السينما الجديده وجائزه جولدربي
وجائزه الجمعيه السينمائيه الدوليه وترشح
لجوائز مهمه كال بافته
والاوسكار جمع ماسكال حتى اليوم ثروه تقدر
بنحو مليوني دولار واصبح نجما لامعا يحتل
مكانه مرموقه بين النجوم الكبار وينافس
على اهم البطولات في سماء هوليود